Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Kapagann, ich bin hier zuständiger Eistin.
Mit Ihnen werde ich das Anamnese-Gespräch führen.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwärmung sprechen, möchte ich ein paar Allgemeine fragen stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Tag Frau Doktorin.
Guten Tag.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Heinrich.
Heinrich?
Wackenhaus.
Okay, Herr Wackenhaus, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, natürlich, das ist nicht so alltäglich der Name.
Wackenhaus ist Wehenwalter, Anton César, Karikarn, Emil Nordfohlen und dann Haus Wehenhaus.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
23. August.
20. August.
19. 155.
Okay, Herr Wackenhaus, wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin circa 1,73 m.
73 m.
Und mein Gewicht sind circa 98 kg.
98 kg? Okay.
Herr Wackenhaus, was für ist es zu uns?
Frau Doktor, ich habe seit ein paar Tagen Verwachschmerzen.
Verwachschmerzen?
Ja, die sind sehr unterschiedlich, aber die nehmen jetzt immer mehr zu.
Das wird immer schlechter als Schmerzen.
Deswegen bin ich heute bei Ihnen.
Okay.
Da sind Ihre Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Genau, das ist schlimmer geworden.
Das hat auch Intensität zugenommen.
Es war vorher nur ab und zu.
Und jetzt kommt es eigentlich fast jede Stunde.
Herr Wackenhaus, könntest du Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ist es drückend, stehend, pochend?
Mehr zum Teil erkrankt, würde ich sagen.
Das ist oft im oberen Bauch.
Und dann schnürt sich der Magel ein bisschen zusammen, habe ich das Gefühl.
Und mir ist zeitweise übel.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, es strahlt so im oberen Bereich aus
und geht auch so ein bisschen in den Bauch hinein.
Ist das Gürtel für mich?
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Keine Schlecht sagen, aber...
Das ist da oben sich ausstrahlt.
Das macht mir jetzt Angst, weil es auch so ein bisschen
manchmal nach oben hin ein bisschen brennt.
Haben Sie Sot brennen?
Das ist ähnlich, es könnte dazu passen.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnot?
Luftnot habe ich jetzt nicht.
Hätten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Vor 20 Jahren hatte ich mal so leichte Sot brennen.
Aber das ist seitdem nicht mehr.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Auf meiner Schmerzskolopon nur bis 10, wenn du kein Schmerzen
und 10 sehr starker Schmerzen meint?
Normalerweise sind es so 3 bis 4, würde ich sagen.
Jetzt in letzter Zeit ist es sicherlich bis 8 angestiegen.
8.
Ich habe gesagt, dass Ihre Schmerzen in ihrer Oberbauch ausstrahlen.
Ja, da.
Gibt es bestimmte Aussprache für Ihre Beschwerden?
Es ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Nach dem Essen wird es manchmal schlimmer.
Und ich habe oft Übelkeit.
Ansonsten auch wenn ich etwas trinke,
in letzter Zeit wird es auch schlimmer.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Übelkeit haben.
Mussten Sie sich schon einmal erbrochen?
Erbrechen?
Nein, erbrochen habe ich bisher nicht.
Aber manchmal hat man das Gefühl,
dass man so ein leichter Brechreiz hat.
Einverstanden.
Mussten Sie so ausstosen?
Manchmal ja.
Herr Watkenhaus, gibt es etwas,
das Ihre Beschwerden Lindert oder verstärkt?
Lindert, ich habe es bisher mit verschiedensten Getränkern,
Kamilität und so weiter probiert, aber es hat nichts gebracht.
Ich habe auch einen speziellen Magenthe getrunken,
aber das hat auch nicht geholfen.
Mit Verstärken haben wir gerade schon besprochen,
dass beim Essen oder nach dem Trinken,
es schlimmer wird.
Können Sie gut schlucken?
Schlucken geht noch.
Herr Watkenhaus, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit
ungewollt, ab oder zu gehen?
Nein, so.
Mein Gewicht ist seit Jahren immer stabil.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit beim anderen Arzt dagegen?
Nein.
Deswegen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie oder haben Sie irgendeine Medikamente,
bis weh, genau?
Ja, wegen Ihrer Beschwerden.
Wegen Ihrer Beschwerden?
Einabwägbar, ich muss mal kurz mal die Tür zu machen,
das wird jetzt ein bisschen lauter da hinten.
Entschuldigung.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen dauerhaft oder well upon?
Ja, das kommt immer wieder.
Ich würde nicht sagen, ihr er krampfartig,
aber das kommt immer sehr geholft und verstärkt jetzt.
Okay.
Herr Watkenhaus,
haben Sie Probleme bei dem Stuhlgang und Wasserlasten?
Nein, bis jetzt ist alles okay.
Okay.
Gusten Sie?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Herzdosen oder Herzklopfen?
Mit dem Herzen habe ich bisher eigentlich keine Probleme gehabt.
Haben Sie enge Gefühle?
Wie auf der Brust, meinen Sie?
Ja.
Ach so.
Nein, das jetzt nicht, aber jetzt im Rahmen dieser Schmerzen
habe ich manchmal so ein bisschen Brennen auf der Brust.
Aber so ein enge Gefühl würde ich jetzt Nein sagen.
Haben Sie brännende Schmerzen in Ihrer Brustbein?
Hinter dem Brustbein?
Also manchmal ist es so, dass es, ich habe das mal so,
hier vorne im Magenbereich, da brennt es so nach oben ein bisschen.
Nicht immer.
Okay.
Haben Sie volle Gefühle nach dem Essen?
Ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, mein Bauch ist voller Luft.
Ja, fühlen Sie sich wie ein Ballon.
Ja, wie aufgeblasen, das stimmt.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder war Ihnen nicht schwindelig?
Nein, ich habe jetzt keinen Nein.
Okay, Herr Wackenhaus, möchte ich für Sie
Kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Und Sie haben...
Was möchte ich machen? Ich habe Sie nicht ganz verstanden.
Ich möchte für Sie kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Zusammenfassung? Ah, okay.
Seit ein paar Tagen leiden Sie unter Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ihre Schmerzen sind zunehmend und kremfartig.
Ja, Sie leiden unter Sortbrennen und nach dem Essen
fühlen Sie sich sehr schlecht.
Und haben Sie auch Rechreis und Ihre Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Und Ihre Schmerzintensität ist von Tag zu Tag angestellt.
Angestiegen, genau.
Angestiegen.
Okay.
Herr Wackenhaus, haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen,
ich weiß zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Blutzuckerkrankheit,
Schichtdürsenunterfunktion?
Ja, ich nehme seit einigen Jahren Medikamente gegen hohen Blutdruck.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter?
Das sind so circa 15 Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Und dann nehme ich zwei Medikamente ein.
Wie ist das?
Wissen Sie das Name?
Das eine heißt, ich glaube, Amlodipin, Milligramm.
Und das andere nennt sich Carvedilol.
25 Milligramm.
Täglich einmal nehmen Sie...
Ja, ich nehme beides jeweils morgens ein Stück.
Amlodipin, welche Dosierung?
50 Milligramm.
Ansonsten keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Ja, und mein Hausarzt hat mich zu einem Spezialistin geschickt,
weil er so durch Blutungsstörungen bei mir in Bayern vermutet hatte.
Und seitdem nehme ich aspirin 100.
Haben Sie Darangeliten?
Hat man festgestellt zum ersten Mal vor circa fünf Jahren.
Medikamente, die Medikamente, name Sie ASS.
Genau, ASS 100.
Ansonsten, keine.
Also, ich habe auch noch die Cholesterin-Tabletten genommen,
aber die habe ich nicht vertragen, deswegen habe ich sie abgesetzt.
Ich habe Cholesterin-Tabletten.
Aber ich habe da Muskelschmerzen bekommen,
und deswegen habe ich sie abgesetzt.
Im Moment nehme ich keine.
Haben Sie Ihre Cholesterin-Tabletten kontrolliert?
Nein, meine Hausarzt kontrolliert die regelmäßig.
Die sind leicht erhöht, aber das ist okay, sagt mein Hausarzt.
Können Sie mich nicht, Frau Doktor?
Ich möchte nicht.
Wie ist es jetzt?
Ja, ich will nicht.
Ja, ist besser.
Meine Netzverbindung ist nicht richtig.
Die Netzverbindung ist nicht so gut.
Also, mein letzter Wort war, der mein Hausarzt kontrolliert,
meine Hinwerte regelmäßig, sagt immer, die sind leicht erhöht,
aber das ist okay.
Ja, vielleicht können Sie Sport treiben.
Ja, sollte ich eigentlich, aber ich bin eigentlich sehr faul.
Ich stehe jetzt, folgen Sie vielleicht.
Okay, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, das war keine richtige OP, aber ich bin am Knie schon einmal untersucht worden.
Ich habe eine Knie-Spiegelung, eine Atroskopie.
Brauen Sie keine Knieersatz?
Nein, nein, da waren, mein Menisgruß war gerissen,
und das hat sich eingeschaut, der Orthopäde, und hat es ein bisschen zusammengeflickt.
Mit der Atroskopie-Verfahren.
Okay, haben Sie alle Grundimpfungen erhalten und sind Sie vollständig geöffnet gegen Corona?
Ja, also ich bin auch geboostert.
Ich bin auch mit den anderen Impfungen komplett.
Mein Haus hat kontrolliert das immer wieder.
Da ist er sehr konsequent.
Entschuldigung, haben Sie bestimmte Allergie gegen etwas?
Ich habe eine leichte Polenallergie.
Und gegen ein Antibiotikum.
Wie heißt das noch mal?
Nein, das ist nicht anders.
Das nennt sich, glaube ich, Zipro, Flock, Sazino.
Verstanden.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Früher hatte ich mal geraucht, aber es ist schon lange her.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Vielleicht so zehn Jahre.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu mal.
Im Gesellschaft trinken Sie?
Ja, genau, wenn wir feste sind.
Oder manchmal zum Abendessen.
Nicht so viel.
Diese Frage ist nicht persönlich, sondern medizinische Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nichts zu tun.
Verstanden.
Herr Wackenhaus, den Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die haben bisher keine Krankheit.
Denen geht es gut.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Ehre, zusammen?
Ja, wir wohnen zusammen.
Sind Sie momentan Rentner?
Ich bin seit,
circa vier Jahren Rentner.
Ich habe so meine Hobbys, mit denen ich mich beschäftige.
Ja, gut zu entscheiden.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, die sind leider schon verstorben.
Wollern Sie gestorben?
Meine Eltern.
Meine Mutter, als Heimatdemenz.
Ich habe sie schon gestorben.
Als Heimatdemenz.
Ich habe sie ziemlich mitgenommen.
Und mein Vater hat den Herz entfragt.
Sind Sie ein Kind?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder und zwei Schwester.
Sind Ihre Geschwister gesund?
Ja, meine Schwester hatte letztes Jahr leider
ein Brustkrebs.
Die Diabetes-Kröte muss operiert werden.
Aber im Moment geht es sehr gut.
Die andere Schwester hat Diabetes und andere Erkrankungen,
die ich jetzt nicht genau weiß.
Und mein Bruder hat es leider seit einigen Jahren Depressionen.
Okay.
Aber hat sich jetzt eigentlich relativ gut stabilisiert,
in den Medikamente eines Killingbrut?
Ja, Ihre Zustände sind stabil.
Okay.
Herr Wackenhaus, von meiner Seite aus habe ich alle
richtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Frau Doktor Sehlin.
Sie haben noch etwas eingefallen.
Sie haben sich sehr viel zeichnet und vielen Dank.
Ich habe jetzt Angst, ob es etwas Schlimmes ist.
Was werden Sie jetzt machen?
Man sollte nicht nur an schlimmste Ursachen denken,
sondern so viele Ursachen für Ihre Beschwerden.
Und jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und von Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Und mit Ultrachalkontrollieren.
Ich werde Ihre Bauch kontrollieren.
Okay.
Und mit dem Ergebnis werde ich mit meinem Chef,
mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Dann komme ich wieder zu Ihnen zurück.
Ich werde alles erklären.
Heute gemacht?
Ja, heute werden wir alles.
Ich werde Sie bei uns bleiben.
So weiter Procedere.
Ja, meine Kollegin.
Haben Sie angeschwollene Beine?
Die Beine? Nein.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen? Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie angeschwollene Beine?
Nein, ich habe nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe nicht.
Haben Sie in betroffenen Bereich
Verferbung?
Wo genau? Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
An Ihren Bauch.
Ach so, Bauch? Nein.
Verferbung habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen.
Noch mehr Fragen vor Doktor?
Nein, nein.
Gut.
Sollen wir dann Übergabe machen?
An den Oberarzt?
Wenn von den Kollegen seien im Moment keine Fragen kommen,
dann können wir Fragen auch später am Ende besprechen.
Okay, bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich habe schon einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Herr Henry Wackenhaus ist 67-jähriger Patient.
Und 1,73 m groß und 98 kg schwer.
Herr Henry Wackenhaus stellte sich bei uns
wegen seit ein paar Tagen Kraftartiger,
Sunneemender, Oberbauchschmerzen
vor, Diadiese Schmerzen
strahlten in Brust, in der Brustkorb auch aus.
Allein nicht strahlten, aber strahlten?
Wandern. Wandern auch.
Nein, strahlten.
Okay, strahlten.
Strahlten an ihren Brustkorb auch aus.
Und ja, die Schmerzintensität
sein in der letzten Zeit von 3-4 zu 8
gestiegen, die Schmerzen sein,
nach dem Essen oder die Schmerzen sein,
postprandial aufgetreten.
Und die Patienten leiden unter Brechreis.
Und die Schmerzen sein, dauerhaft.
Vor 20 Jahren hatten die Patienten
unter Brechreis,
und die Übelkeit auch,
die Schmerzen sein, dauerhaft.
Ja, vor 20 Jahren hatten die Patienten
wir in die Schmerzen beschwerden,
aber es war sehr leicht.
Und ja, okay.
Der Patient leide an einer arterellen
Vertonierung, seit 15 Jahren,
dagegen nehmen sie am Lodipin 5 mg
und Karvedilon 25 mg täglich einmal.
Und außerdem leide er an,
außerdem sei er vor 5 Jahren
an Perfoka Erkrant,
dagegen nehmen sie momentan
100 mg täglich einmal ein.
Der Patient wurde wegen menuschisis
durchgeführt.
Er sei vollständig geimpft.
Er habe Polenallergie
und Cypherofloxacinallergie.
Er hat eine Artroskopie durchgeführt.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Er sei nicht Raucherin,
vor 10 Jahren,
habe er mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol,
ein Drogenkonsum,
Er hatte zwei gesunden Kinder, momentan sei er Rentner.
Und in der Familienanamnese gab er
ein Alzheimer bei der Mutter und einer Mio-Kartinfarkt bei dem Vater.
Seine Eltern sind schon gestorben.
Die erhabe drei Geschwister, ein Bruder leide an einer Depression,
eine Schwester sei an Brustkrebs erkrankt und andere Schwester leide an Diabetes mellitus.
Die an amnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Ulkospeptikus hin.
Ulkosventrykuli.
Duodini.
Als differenzial Diagnose kommen eine Ulkos-Duaedoni und
eine Polycystolitis.
Und Polydokolitis in Frage.
Zur weiteren Abkühlerung werde ich zuerst Körperlunterzuholen.
Ich werde mit Ultraschall seinen Bauch kontrollieren.
Und falls ich etwas von der Diagnose durchführe.
Eine Magendahmspiegel.
Magendahmspiegel.
Ja.
Okay.
Noch differenzial Diagnostisch?
Ja.
Pancreas Gengestein oder Papillostein.
Okay, zum Beispiel.
Genau.
Und ja, Acut pancreatitis.
Acute pancreatitis.
Ja.
Was noch?
Die anderen können helfen so ein bisschen.
Wo sind die anderen?
Heute ist die Gruppe sehr leise.
Ja.
Mitmachen.
Woran denkt man noch differenzial Diagnostisch?
Die Äktik ist sehr alt.
Schmerzen, Sternal.
Ja, myocard.
Also, Sie sind auch an ein Herz mal denken, genau.
Natürlich.
Myocard, in fact, auch.
Genau. Und Sie haben vorhin gesagt, Cholocystolitis.
Cholocystolitis macht keine Beschwerden.
Eine Cholizystitis macht Beschwerden.
Okay. Kennen Sie den Unterschied?
Ja, Cholizystitis ist Galenblaseentsundung.
Und Cholitis.
Cholitis.
Es gibt Schalne in der Galenblase.
Und das macht normalerweise keine Schmerzen.
Nur wenn es ein Zünder zählt.
Also eine Cholizystitis.
Genau.
Andere Differenzialdiagnose.
Nein, ich habe nicht gesagt.
Ich habe Pancreas, Karcinum.
Pancreas natürlich.
Und ja, Magne Karcinum auch.
Ja, auch.
Astroesophageal, Refluxkrankheit.
Ein Reflux. Ja, sehr gut.
Eine Reflux-Oesophageitis. Richtig?
Sehr gut.
Also, haben wir, also erst mal, Dankeschön, Frau Doktor.
Das war sehr gut.
Aber Sie sind heute ein bisschen unkonzentriert.
Da habe ich den Eindruck, Sie bewechseln immer,
machen eher und dann Sie.
Bei der Prüfung kann es manchmal,
wenn da ein blöder Prüfer da ist.
Das heißt, Sie sollten immer darauf achten,
wenn es ein Herr ist oder männlich,
dass Sie auch immer die männliche Form benutzen.
Sie sagen immer, wenn der Patient etwas erzählt,
Einverstanden.
Nein, Sie möchten sagen, ja, ich habe verstanden
oder sagen Sie einfach, okay, nicht Einverstanden.
Einverstanden heißt, ich akzeptiere das, was Sie sagen.
Also einfach sagen, okay, ich habe verstanden.
Verstanden, nicht Einverstanden.
Einverstanden bedeutet etwas anderes.
Verstanden heißt, ich habe verstanden, was Sie gesagt haben.
Oder so wie Sie es jetzt gesagt haben, okay.
Und dann müssen gar nichts sagen.
Ja?
Und bei der Übergabe an den Oberarzt
verwechseln Sie immer die Zeit.
Dann haben Sie einmal Vergangenheit benutzt
und dann waren Sie in, war das passiv?
Ja, genau.
Dann müssen Sie achten, dass Sie immer in der gleichen Zeit bleiben
oder in der gleichen Form, wenn Sie eine Übergabe machen.
Und, das wollte ich noch eins, zwei, noch.
Genau, angestiegen.
Angestiegen.
Angestiegen und angestiegen.
Nicht gesteigert.
Es gibt auch, die Werte sind angestiegen
oder die Werte sind steigert.
Das sagt man nicht so, die sind eher angestiegen.
Angestiegen.
Ansonsten machen Sie sehr gut
und machen auch die Anomlese ganz gut.
Das ist schon sehr, sehr toll.
Danke schön.
Und am Wochenende hören wir eine schöne, positive Antwort von Ihnen.
Ich hoffe auch.